foreign
Charles is with us Charles is in Phoenix
Arizona hi Charles how are you
hey Dave Rachel I'm good how are you
better than we deserve what's up
I was calling because I'm having a bit
of trouble over the last two years my
question is how can I work towards
budgeting with my wife we've been
married for two years I was working on
the baby steps before marriage we got
married and anything Dave Ramsey or Dave
Ramsey personality my wife despises not
to just reality of it and
um anything anytime I bring up a budget
or talking through the budget or
sticking to the budget
um it's like scratching meals on a
chalkboard to her so since since Rachel
and I are so lovable if she despises us
that would be your fault
for the record she didn't like you
before she married me
well then you got yourself into this I
don't think I can help you
I'm nicer Charles maybe she'll like me
so tomorrow follow me on Instagram now
you're a Ramsey personality he already
said there I know she just may lump me
in with you you know we're two separate
people oh wow so maybe she would like
a female perspective I don't know okay
I've had lots of women say so okay I got
on board because of Rachel it's really
not us that she doesn't like because she
never met us
um so we're not offended by that but
there's something that we are asking are
suggesting that she do that she's
opposed to and that would be controlling
her spending or that would be putting up
with you being a control freak and
telling her what to do all the time or
that would be there's something that she
Associates us with
that's negative because being a grown-up
and telling your money what to do is not
something people generally oppose
it's been opposed to me it's the the
common phrase is I'm not living like I'm
broke well okay there's the objections
yeah there's the objection okay so she
Associates us with uh extreme frugality
to a ridiculous level with no point
yeah and that's not it's not actually
what we teach obviously well we teach
Extreme frugality for a short period of
time so that you can live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else it's the later part
that she hasn't gotten or doesn't
believe that can happen or doesn't
believe it can happen okay so
um obviously you're gonna have to take a
different approach than you've taken
and if you've turned us into a cuss word
you can never mention us again
I don't for the record yeah I haven't
for about a year doesn't do any good
okay so I think you guys need marriage
counseling
I've tried
okay
um then you're probably not then you're
probably not gonna make it
because if she says you're not worth
our relationship is not worth
working on
she's made she's giving you a really
loud statement
I understand what's uh Charles what's
her what what does she oppose that that
factor right that you marriage
counseling what's what is her opposition
towards that what does she say
it's not really an opposition more of a
I don't get a straightforward opposition
it's more of a
kind of a Dodge of the question or the
topic I don't I'm not a my opinion is
maybe she doesn't feel that she needs it
or that we need it but I've brought it
up several times I myself
um I'm all in favor of counseling and
and therapy and help I myself started
going to one or a therapist earlier this
year just to improve myself see if I can
be a better husband to my wife but a
father to our kid I think I think your
therapist needs to guide you through
these relationship issues I don't think
we're qualified
okay because I don't think this is about
a budget and I don't think this is about
Ramsay personalities or Dave Ramsey I
think I think this is about she's been
hurt she's scared she's angry
um she doesn't trust there's a lot going
on here that I don't even know what it
is
um and apparently you don't either at
this stage and that's what you guys have
got to work on you've got to get to
where you uh love each other and and
will do anything for each other to serve
each other and have a great future
together and right now everything that
comes up to better your life you get a
big Shield that comes up and that's
based on fear or based on anger yeah
there's other stuff going on there's
other stuff going on there and it's not
it's not us I mean it's not it's not a
there's not we're not the problem and so
we're also not the solution
that's what it comes down to so I'm
sorry you're facing that man it's a hard
thing to go through especially in a
two-year-old marriage I mean it's just
awful it's just not it's supposed to be
it's supposed to be better than this you
know but yeah I think your therapist
needs to give you
um some very specific things to draw
out and and you know because this is not
a sustainable relationship the way it's
operating
you're not going to be 40 years from
today still married doing it this way
I mean because people finally they just
get enough and they're not going to
they're not living she's going to get
enough she's going to run out with her
hair on fire or vice versa so you have
to be growing and working together or
you can't stay together in a culture
where nobody stays together I've been
married 41 years Sharon says we had 30
years of good marriage
uh actually she used to say that when it
was 37 there's about about seven years
in there you know and yeah it's bad for
the first years were rough and uh but
yeah it's and it was mostly on me so in
that case I don't know if this is on you
I don't know if you're being controlling
and you're not you don't sound like it
in this call but it doesn't mean you're
not
and the positive spin Charles is if if
you guys get to that place I think
there's always the beauty in your two
years in which means the habits and what
you guys can create as a foundation of
your marriage can be a real yeah I mean
you guys may just be doing this head
Collision that some people don't
experience so 10 years down the road
you're doing it two years uh but I I
hope that it I hope that it works out
and that you guys can see yourselves as
a team and again like you said just
continuing to grow
and who you are as people
um and stuff yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
bet that there's a lot of stuff going on
in her so and she may not even know
that's the other thing that's what's
hard that's what that's what a good
therapist would do I really pray she
would go because they're the ones that
can unpeel those layers and that so much
of the unconscious that we live that
comes out in these ways Right comes out
that oh I don't want to I don't want to
do I don't want to budget oh don't
control my money I don't want to work on
myself like there's there's a reason
she's dodging all if you say don't say
Financial Peace don't say Dave Ramsey
original cruise to me ever if you're out
there and you you have a spouse saying
that then it's your fault because you've
used us as a weapon
and we're not a weapon we're teachers
and so you used us to try to control
them and they don't want to be
controlled so instead of persuading you
tried to use a club
and that's not how marriage and how
relationships work and so you know if if
I if we have become a cuss word in your
marriage that's your fault because we
didn't do anything to become a cuss word
except try to help you and we're not
offended by that it's not we're not
there's no defensiveness at all in that
it's just funny and but but and it makes
great jokes and those are all fun we can
have we can we could do all that stuff
but the bottom line is is that you know
you're being too stinking controlling or
you're using this as a club instead of
you know hey I learned this great new
thing to get out of debt we're going to
sell your car honey you know Dave Ramsey
said you know that that was dumber than
a rock it didn't work